oui ça je suis en pleine forme fabien on
est surtout which you to which de
partout à cheval salut youtube youtube
ont tant m on est très très hostile à
youtube des gens qui regardent on vivait
et les gens qui regardent l'émission
aurait pu emmener au style de ce soir
est très hostile mais on attend que les
gens arrivent quand même pas vraiment et
surtout il avoué
c'est bien le moins difficile mais
affable ebe à il est déjà en spectateur
tu regardes et tu te regarde
ouais bah je te voir si ça marche je ne
me vois pas comment tu peux voir qui est
là je ne suis pas au courant
ouais j'ai mes secrets et porte d'entrée
alors attends la drh étaient hyper chaud
sur le chat de check point com et les
gens étaient encore plus chaude sur le
chat de twitch en fait du coup on tue
les révéla répondent ils sont chauds
donc je vais aller les voir bahia je les
ouvre je suis aussi mme g qui arrivent
nous le dur et quand même envie vont pas
être contents parlant des conneries tu
parle français dégâts je veux plus voir
sur cette date vous nombreux diamant
famille
ouais c'est toi bon il ya des gens qui
regardent nous on est on est à une 105
s'élancer escorte il salue 22 mai drip
98 il ya imada qui est très très
contents ils te répondent en anglais
[Musique]
farid alfheim maroc est passé mais tu
parles il était là la semaine dernière
autour on est venu du coup les gens vont
pouvoir mixer contre toi ce soir ou même
des gens à tout le monde en fait je vais
aller sur la zone de jeu et c'est parti
déjà je suis sur la zone jaune à la
buissière jouer oui c'est parce qu'à se
passer l'âge où je l'attends les défis
donc ça du 3-0 d'enseignants des parties
de jeu contre le big country one jack
black jack peut-être une petite modernes
ont peut-être big ben ou qui on a déjà
un bon alors bon juste ce truc en fait
pour ça bon je crois je perds ça et si
j'imagine je le faire ça une station
jeune fille naïve très content et le pin
up mais on va garder l'eau qu'une puce
après avoir des conversations de
produits ben voilà il est là le clan +11
pure est un pion un iphone is open à ce
que les mecs c'est fun je veux dire je
pense qu'il faut que je devais 6% voire
un peu des lignes tout ça pas mal bon
bah je te prends pas donc vous êtes un
modèle plus mai puis en double je
t'attaque des six otages eux deux pions
de plus alors mais pas qui tu le laisses
nom mettant en veilleuse ce qu'on peut
faire pour bien attaquer en fait ce
n'est pas juste beaucoup mieux ici
maintenant je ne comprends pas en fait
parce que dans mon livre tu as un fond
plus que de plus en plus est pas mal
joli dessin qui est intéressant
bon bah j'irai beaucoup des cinq ans
mais ma femme ouais ils connaissent un
caïd essebsi bien protégé semaines le
barça entre 70 et ses 4 j'aime me paraît
au début on repart en jeu des fautes
lourdes de judo choses sont claires et
c'est vrai mais il va garder il va voir
arriver avoir des compensations
non ne me dis pas ça pour quoi je ne
veux pas qu'il y ait de compensation
l'asie mais regarde caille c4 on te dit
avoir aussi son sais pas si c'est il
peut y va le voir il va faire drôle si
ce nombre il a vraiment bien vu mais
termine définitivement à tout jamais de
le faire du quatuor alain fogué verser 5
j'imagine oui je t'aime des bons ce que
je lui laisse sur son son truc et c'est
un peu comme dans les cheveux je voulais
que défendre bêtement dans un benneteau
n'ont longtemps je tire de partout en
fait c'est débile caillou de ces big pun
il est là 21
c'est facile de jouer et postule fink
haïti
[Musique]
assez pabbi peine 19 ans habite l'ogc
nice est moins fort la tétée niveau 21
tu gagnes commencé à tabit peine 22 qui
t'attend bon bah tant pis y'a d'la merde
j'ai pas du tout un jeu ça va je vais
faire regarder de plus près de leurs
produits qu'ils pensaient d'autres comme
si on gagne à deux en plus le chien je
vais montrer pour les auditeurs à temps
ne bouge pas 3d de chez eux
c'est mauvais ouais bon
moi ça me rappelle les matches de pro de
chez slick de regarder cette partie
fabien tu es bien et puis après on sent
que tu glisses quoi de faire tomber deux
il va te faire tout point à 2 que tu as
peut être qualifié cinq échecs mais même
si tu fais même s'il est fou prend des
trois j'allais dire écarts et des c4
après c'est pénible un ceccarelli ces
quatre là c'est bon quand on veut plus
de pièces possibles d'ici
ce cas là bas donc c'est un pion de plus
qui ne vaut rien mais c'est un peu tous
non mais t'es pas ou moins bien non on a
une petite phase difficile à passer mais
là on est de nouveau dans la partie ces
deux là je parle bien ou mal non mais
t'es un peu obligé la can de jeu pour le
gain en fin j'ai reçue n'a pas l'aura de
pages le prologue a montré que l'europe
politique
peut-être avec faire tomber cette
poussée cinq noms mais avec de la tourbe
et sa 306 via torrent qui menace non non
non j'y vais faut que tu passes de
l'autre côté
montez pas mal d'être de nouveau là on
va peut-être des choses mais en plus le
cavalier est super bien contrôlé par ton
roi un truc qui n'a juste pas faire
regarder trop ce qu'on sait de s'ignorer
man et là du coup tu vas faire du tour
j'ai quatre enfants hcap tête
en fait on joue comme ça il en crée une
sorte de gros pions ok mais contrôle
quelques petites cases importante e3
pour le cavalier les protège des pions
attention de pas sarrois détroit non
mais ça va là tu vas tu va gérer main je
garde en tête le truc mon genre je crois
donc sage à une cache de cloront oui il
va peut-être se faire qu'à idée de après
attention il va menacer car il ya enfin
marie vas-y maintenance et j'avais peur
qu'il fasse souvent un échec courageux
et qui a aidé de du coup bonjour part
dans l'autre sens mais qu'il en d2 il
est mal placée avec sa tour tu pries
peux pas te remettre un échec il n'a pas
super bien joué en fait un il aurait pu
le faire tour à tour machin et il aurait
put presque deux forfaits d'affaires nul
puisque là du coup qu'est ce que tu fous
quoi tu as appris h 15 chez bosch
attendant je vais tomber
c'est insupportable bon bah c'est pas ça
2500 ont validé l'idée du stream donc
c'est le vin
alors j'ai un défi parce qu'on se batte
mon record
big lots nouvelle bouleversante récoltes
records
le bcm a pour ce soir peut-être mais tu
peux le battre a apprécié que tu pas
très bien sur internet et brew nous être
différents pions yg environ un retard
d'au
comme miroir retardé optimiste quand je
te prends chez nous maintenant tu vas
pas finir vaste histoire avec les
demi-heures celui qui sait ce que c'est
ça qu'est ce qu'il fait en face je sais
pas elle était surprise et mon groupe de
retarder ok tu vas y j'espère ces trois
des quatre mois ouais bon sur ses trois
niveaux cherche machin ou même choisir
chaud au 3 janvier
ils furent acquis salut les gars content
de voir un stream est un ravin qui salue
tous nominés autre chose il salua tous
ces trois des quatre est très bien je
prends le sens pas je prends le sentent
jamais restructure je te réponds aux
plats salés partie technique du ça passe
d'un gang dit roy retardé en en bon
c'est pas c'est comment ils appellent
surclassement comme cette variante non
l'aveyron léonard 10 j'aime beaucoup ce
nom leonardi ce ne sont là si on me
donne envie de la jouer fort que tu
stabilise un peu ta position que
développe des pièces à prêteurs un bel
avantage quand même avec la structure
demeure
c'est ça notre peau stabiliser bon le
truc sur food et 5 40 tours j'ai juste
faire flouer 302 par trois points de
charge et deux jeux tijeras qui veut
faire comprendre ça vaut de prendre des
risques pas dans les clous âge
c'est très très bien ouais bon
j'aimerais bien voir meilleur des deux
pompes sa femme ok ça 24.3 tout optique
ois sentir la pièce je positive et que
le cavaliere f3 s'est protégé h2 et le
fou en b 5
bon il ya plein de placement jesse
possible assez clair que les vents sont
mieux voilà où s'invite ce que m
on a joué pour l'activité on sait jamais
ce qui peut se passer mais objectivement
sur c'est sûr que c'est bien paul
bolufer cailloux 4
l'idée ce n'est pas de prendre avec six
épisodes prendront d ici c'est de mettre
le foin 4 et détruire complètement la
structure depuis lundi vers statut
serait très très bien pas reculer
attention elle est très très mal
mais ça bon je te prends ton four vous
faut être quatre c'est quand même assez
mal fabien et j'éprouve à thuès des cinq
je pense que c'est pas du tout mon style
je pense que tu fais jouer une position
qui a beaucoup de mal à jouer alors il
veut faire des trottoirs s'activer
j'étudie rendement pour une charge
d'adobe tout n'ira préfère b3 c4 ma
chance
m son fond deux tu contrôles du bloc
tout cas là je n'ai pas de statut revoir
mes trois c4
on va avancer la province a envoyé à
fond d'ailleurs d'ailleurs c'est pour
qu'on sort de souci non mais il ya que
j'ai fait c'est 4g concert main assez
fou j'ai simple que des 50 ans de la
tourette a peut-être fait refouler 5 qui
faisait quoi je serais cinq bateaux font
marcher mais je prends dans six d'abord
ban qui affaiblissent ici là il n'y a
pas du tout pas du tout géré cette
partie stratégique 1 le mec moi 9,6 un
bon sens en sa qualité n'est ce pas bon
comme un pion et on va reculer ensuite
le fou le coq est très heureux j'entends
derrière toi fou c'est le 14 juillet
demain il est chaud très chaud
chaque truc de coke est très content je
regarde même pas ce qu'ils jouent trop
ouais non mais c'est vrai que c'est
parce pas méga motivant comme position
il vous faut quand même la finir bon
beaucoup sur ce front et du cou les coqs
c'est sympa ou pas non j'ai assumé par
le pacte n'ont pas très bas brahimi
chantreau à tony parker
mais à part ça j'ai pas d'y croire sont
très poussée c'est que c'est pas un
animal il vient pas de voir mais il te
reconnais à des cinq verges vers sa part
reconnu
non potes je pense que je suis pêcheur
que les volatiles ceux des animaux les
plus intelligents les mecs vol n'a pas
fini de nous ils nous sont supérieurs
d'une certaine manière mc pour les
humains supérieurs à toi comment est ce
que tu t'es embourbé dans cette position
femme je ne sais pas comment tu as fait
pas jugé pas très la fourchette grêle
enfilade quand je trouve mais même après
un tacle faire des cinq plus tôt et tout
ça va être complètement gagnant et c'est
pas très difficile mais bon
du coup digital il sent pousser des
ailes bien attention attention le prd
fourchette bienvenus
tarifs et ours et 1,11 et la gueule
c'est clair bon après pire tout changer
pour faire tomber
c'est moins glorieux
ça gagne aussi tu as vu que je suis là
pour votre ton record ce sont tous des
[ __ ] sont bonnes à prendre
ça ça peut être un fil rouge seul objet
qu il a réussi sur ce stream l'armée en
général toute ma vie pendant cinq ans
encore là où je veux défoncé mais
j'avais fait un super âge de malades un
moment donné j'avais défoncer des mecs
assez fort à la volée tu vois alors jean
noël partie avec un terme mais ne veut
pas jouer qu'on veut voir les spylo
seront de 17 alors bonne nouvelle
messieurs vous avez cités dortoirs
j'ai trois bons joueurs comme toi on a
l'habitude de faire avec ce que comme
digital m'a déçu du voyage 5 1 sur ce
coup je crois je méprise complètement en
fait on voit cette une cible ce pion des
revenus de 6 même si mauvais g35
d'ailleurs n'ont pas forcément belge
l'annoncé mais c'est ce que c'est
jouable en partie longue il ya il va de
son corps un bouquet d fait un truc
répond unis font se défont voir ses 4,5
g 3 sont passés assez logique mais qui
rate un ghetto non le 20 mai quand
j'avais joué contre frais se taille tels
tu sais que ça une bonne position j'ai
fait des 4 juillet 6h quatre mois toi tu
en tires ou tu pointes et toi et après
je les fais h 5 h si c'est qu'on lève
une fois ci c'est fait j'ai 4 c'est une
grande améliorer tutu pousse ses pions
sur thème courant tous niveaux je ne
comprenais pas ça pas la théorie
conventionnelles les ouvertures
attention
est ce la gueule quoi après la légalité
des méthodes et une grotte pas tu ne ris
pas tu l'as eu mais croquer ou tu raques
de l'autre côté maria mandy mandjeck
hubinon que ce que vous faites d'abord
où je joue le grand maître fabien
business qui essayent de battre mon
record sur chaque point comme en fait
ils commencent ce soir il à 100 points
de retard encore mais il s'approche il
est motivé il est motivé comme jamais
motivé comme jamais il est à fond voire
de faire de la tv à easy avant d'arrêter
les échecs est ce que je peux quelque
part était sur une bonne note c'est vrai
que comme que des coups de merde
bon c'est pas bien même une interview de
garry kasparov my objective is longue
terme is to beat de riz cordes bitstream
du régime c'est pour ça qu'il revient à
saint louis mais une saint louis tout
rain in order to beat kendrick horde
sanchez d'autres causes après ils vont
arriver dans nos villes de plaire à will
play against will be strong enough is
the war map ce warm-up events avec un
peu plus du coup tu es quand même très
très bien une nouvelle fois abaissé
digital n'est quand même pas à
mentionner tous si on est tous les deux
grands maintenant que fabien je vais
bien et magic cube se dit qu'on est sapé
comme jamais ouanna chemise mais moi je
prenais mes os et pour pour les matchs
championne du monde du coup je suis sapé
comme jamais il ya norman bates qui fait
plaisir ni moi je kiffe les vidéos sur
kasparov et autres c'est bien mieux que
des partis en bidon on ne retient rien
très bien normal
il est exactement ce qu'on pense la
bidouille accord net était génial j'ai
appris plein de trucs bah en fait tu
pense exactement ce qu'on pense en fait
ben là c'est plutôt de l'inter times en
fait ça pour s'amuser mais si tu vas
prendre des trucs en gardant des parties
en blitz en direct c'est pas l'école
bozzini quoi t'as pas pris son curé veut
non parce qu'il y avait des quatre sites
en vtg des quatre à ne pas enfermer
je vais montrer intéressant attention
piège c'est un monde qui jouent alors
c'est lui qui joue c'est fabien c'est le
moins que l'on ne me fabien et lèvent la
main dès demain monsieur fabien des
visas style je veux répondre présent
tapas et des devoirs
le piège marche
je
ces explosions régal très très heureux
le parrain 3 heures si des gars
voulaient me défier vous pouvez si vous
touchez pas qu'on ait défini ouais tu
challenger challenger
acceptez-vous l'urbanisme a racheté à
base est ce que la main car venant
vraiment voulu faire un jeu de mots ou
est ce que c'est vraiment son sa part
être un nom assez possible en fait face
aux prénoms et arrache son et abbas
je sais pas pourquoi quand je perds tu
es parti et ça ça m'arrive de temps en
temps sur une chaise coin comme je ne
vois pas les coûts note vérisme ou
squats réponse gênée série arrive tu
n'en es tu n'y peut rien mais je leur
parle maurice acheter vérité paris
dirait notre sauce new skies of our
lives of si oxmoze atom bonvalet on a
perdu ce nous sommes tous ensemble ouais
bah tu should we know you want me to
synthétique utilisé le jeu aux quatre et
puis et puis 6 pouces banques et b4
comme peut le faire enfin menaces en
main je crois qu'on y voit là bas tu
prends me retarde alors qu'aïcha qui
devance c'est quand votre prochain live
pour commenter un event et le prochain
veille pour comme interne est bonne
c'est en août 2010 à la gare également
ou not so souscripteurs dubaï garry
kasparov qui va revenir à fond du coup
tu es poussé pékin ou en fait les gens
pensent que parce que tu as un style un
peu stratégique quoi les gens il doit
faire qui sait se fabien xixe s qui sait
ce qu'ils paient des gens qui font
craquer dans le chat étant un joueur
d'anglais j'aimerais juste savoir
comment éviter l'arago zine du coup
beaucoup de joueurs que j'ai affrontée
c'est de transposer alors n'hésite pas à
mettre un commentaire sous la vidéo pour
mathieu qui viendra refaire une vidéo du
coup tu vas dans la vidéo et tu dis
ouais matthew corneille un peu du
bâtiment c 4 cm de terre aussi s'il va
jouer avec des cinq ans huit mètres que
je sautais catalan soit des katanas
copeland et de plus ce type type
anglaise plus cheap mais son bon ami tu
pourras laissait matthieu répondre mais
s'attendait à mathieu il fut accueilli
toutes ses dents montant m&a pas
vraiment tourner en avant une furia on
est un peu furieux d'ailleurs
mais là c'est un massacre cette partie
qu'est ce qui se passe sur les mecs ne
réussissent pas trop à ce check ça
commence à m'énerver que tu gagnes et tu
te rapproches quoi je suis pas content
bon alors les plusieurs écoles dont
québec à trois rivières
non merci je m'exécute les bains du coup
on verra si mathieu mature on doit faire
une vidéo un peu réponse fabien c'est
une question pour mathieu n'hésite pas
l'écrire en commentaire aussi on ne sait
pas quand mathieu il va jouer des
tournois lui aussi la ouais bah désolé
on peut ensemble
bon ben voilà il ya plusieurs écoles
mais il ya aussi né koala est ce qu'il
est une école marrante genre fou 17
tours b 8 je voulais faire à la base
vous soir 17 en béton bien ouais ça
arrête l'école madeleine de l'escalier
alors est ce qu'on te ferais attendant
de faire dame prend à deux là on peut
faire ma part je pense que on va y aller
pour ça c'est le beau jeu façon c'est le
beau jeu c'est le beau jeu bou malhab la
carte chef contre watson faut faire le
beau jeu bon donc les jugements si vous
déjà sur cette partie quoi c'est les
blacks bien une pelle française la
refaire on va être très dangereux pour
le plan de grands travaux c'est l'enfer
avec ses quatre pieds comme une
estonienne la même structure je suis
dans le sens j'en parle toujours de
signer avec sa rivale et les gens
entrent et qui fait que les gens coupent
les vidéos quand tu dis ça c'est quoi je
vois dans les salles publiques jeu très
content de cette similitude
mais voilà pas arrêté de retour pour lui
jouer un mauvais tour en balayant quatre
cavaliers je vous appelle solidaire le
quatre-quarts alliés de fous pas trop ça
ne m'intéresse pas on fait des blagues
non homologué qu'elles veulent rappeler
furia furieux 1
il ya des groupes à vologda de la halle
et la tête batteur
je sais que j'ai eu un nouveau dragon
age et une nouvelle carte légendaire sur
sur place royale mais je suis très
dégoûté parce que j'ai une carte que je
ne voulais pas dans les cartes
légendaire ses mines de sel que je ne
voulais pas c'est un dragon à casque
c'est un gros dunk sur la tête et il
crache du feu
il est donc bah c'est dommage parce que
carte légendaire quand on a très
rarement des nouvelles et j'ai reçu
c'est une carte légendaire et je tombe
sur un wagon de merde quoi j'étais
dégoûté très hostile aux dragons nice un
dragon avec un casse-cou le mec arrive
avec son casque le mec a peur de tout
c'est un bébé dragon ball dragon il
avoue statut cette petite fille nahla
est affaire de fous qui brille ouais
et si fin mai un dragon de lanternes
lire edrip ouais on raconte l'enfer je
suis très déçu par le dragon l'enfer
trophée j'ai entendu typique mais c'est
dire qu avec moi vous vous êtes match
une finale c'est nul segal c'est
forcément beaucoup mieux on était mieux
mais jade en tous points à 88 en plus
ici ni pareil j'ai eu cette carte de
merde c'est fantastique
il était très énervé mais aussi j'étais
très énervé en fait toujours un truc
légendaire du génial j'ai ensuite les
gens des habous dégage club de merde
mais je sais pas si je vais l'utiliser
peut-être quand même tu vois j'ai quand
même essayé ou
booth a fallu refaire des pions doublé
un tout jeune mais c'est un truc que
j'ai appris a pas longtemps à l'air très
sérieusement avec les finales de foot
que de même couleur avec un pont plus
sont pas si souvent que ça gagnante en
fait c'est mieux de recours aux non je
sais pas nice a tout de suite extrapole
non verte est insupportable c'est enfin
voilà gères-tu tomber le record je vais
jouer a été obligé de faire un nouveau
record d'ailleurs je remarque que tu ne
joues contre aucun joueur titre et tu
évites et joueurs titrés mais apprendre
des défis qu'ils me donnent dessus ouais
je retirerai de la fin juin contre soi
et il ne veut pas t'aider à battre mon
record
du coup oui en fait j'ai pas pourquoi je
ne savais pas qu'on avait plein qui
était nulle en fait des finales de foot
de même couleur jusqu'à pas si longtemps
genre un an ou deux ans claudia genre de
blocus c'est vrai mais georges pensait
enfin en fait à cause de l'expression
débiles les fous de tout les fous de
l'âne de foot couleurs opposées sont
nuls du coup par extension sans y penser
je pensais que du coup toutes les
finales au fond d'eux mêmes couleurs
sont gagnantes en fait pas du tout en
fait mais tu prends la logique
ouais je comprends
catherine et surtout l'emploi zinc faire
rager 5 j'imagine oui une note de deux
pions passé lié en finale deux tours les
gens c'est parce que c'est
parce que tu as un prono pour pour les
demies de wimbledon
ça va tout ça ça aussi mais je regarde
beaucoup [ __ ] j'ai été très longue la
chance car elle sait ne soit pas mauvais
tam est ok j'ai juste pas regardé comme
et avait pas mieux en fait cache cette
moquette gestion s'est vite fait si je
vous prie mousse c'est le fun mais c'est
de la folie ce que tu as fait d'après
tour des gens tandis que les tournois
oui mais tu as vu sa main
non mais j'ai peur belle chance que tu
as beaucoup de chance quitte face à
nantes et peut-être pas de chance en
fait à merde t'es quoi d'autre se
perdant dans nos caisses juste après mon
vagin sinon je rectifie je n'aime pas
regarder si ce qui joue à quoi
mais ce retour début nouvelle va faire
du tout rires non mais attendez c'est
sûr ça gagne mais c'est juste dauphin je
jouais pas bien c'est génial même écran
là partout non je ne te laisse pas tout
montrer que bach ou pas nita nulle honte
et était perdant liqin de nous situer à
mars et ils déclinent du carbone
elle est hyper ridicule cette partie
c'est une bouillie d'échec cette partie
sans voix je vais revenir je reviens
avec les gens voir si c'est passé en
fait sur eux deux je me demande ce que
tu pouvais faire en fait un jeu plus
empêcher tard en fait après et du poids
après tt tt perdant mais après wife six
roues arrive ça peut les faires dame
prend h7
alors je suis là depuis safed à me
ranger 50 sait pas pourquoi pour comme
j'avais bien joué la partie s'ils vont
ils méritent
après quoi
c'est bien je très bon gré après à 32
après deux déplacements fait tes rêves à
y sont plus réticents à lavaur se
trouvait encore au rendez-vous pour sa
chérie des ouais moi tu es juste ou
roellinger justement celle où que
j'aille au tempo ne va pas je râle
madame le malin c'est génial
voilà ils nous ont dit par le chat quoi
sur ce point comme officiel non mais là
tu monte à 27 44 95 quel état tu te va
bien
bon bah nouvelle partie d'ailleurs ces
gens veulent édifier donc ceux qui
veulent y aura deux nouvelles marques là
sans doute le premier c'est tout
il m'a dit allez je les accepte 812 il
ya le petit drapeau marocain ont été
vraiment de limayrac ou d'origine
marocaine est la science qui les
marocains
il est pas très lac en fête est annulée
abarth je joue quelqu'un et même à
chaque balise je vais pas l'un deux fois
les attentions et dangereux quand je
regarde un truc puisque bien même si oui
c'est super c'est l'équivalent à revoir
ten des master classes tout on n'a pas
encore décidé d'ailleurs juste quelqu'un
qui écrit un mail pour savoir
voilà non on pense à une initiation
peut-être à la française quelques
parties intéressantes à voir
après je sais pas je serais d'avis
d'attention dont joue vraiment d'envoi
joue pas forcément super bien mais tu
vois il est toujours là en fait si tu
vois ce que je veux dire tu peux t'on
glisser une écluse tout de suite en fait
mais là par contre je comprend pas trop
ce qu'il a fait l'essai à quatre c'est
pas un peu bizarre à brive 6-6 pas à te
défie en direct alors peut-être parce
que c'était fabien était en train de
jouer une partie mais c'est assez
étrange en fait nous n'avançons pas très
ambitieux t'as pas bien la cavale et a6
je viens verser 5 tu veux te battre kg
4e prendre sont fous tu le domine là
l'un des deux m'a dit ok là du duel vous
prendra 4 parce que là en fait c'est
complètement génial d'avoir un pion b2
qui ont un quatre là qui bloque l'option
v2 et venir comme ça merde [ __ ] je
tempo ça va sinon cela donne des hausses
seront fermes biologiques et b3 par
hasard message est prévue ok on chez toi
et du cou du coup ça va mais c'était pas
prévu c'est très dangereux
aux côtés de du coup suggère jeunes
alors dame 2008 6 8 6 et 8
ces huit logique tu as ta pht
éventuellement même si damas six noms
certains au moins notre parcours bon
alors là on peut pousser on peut prendre
pour qu'il y ait des quatre surtout
d'une balade quand même
qu'est-ce que tu joues bien avec une
différence de niveau entre toi et moi ça
me ça me fait flipper en fait non c'est
horrible pas georges suis content inclus
mais je ne suis pas du tout jaloux
quoique ce soir je dis juste ça comme ça
pagis et c'est beaucoup quoi ça fait
plaisir
ouais c'est juste enfin genre comment tu
le massacre c'est magnifique
l'ate a l'embarras du choix en fait tu
encaissé à deux je pensais que ça allait
faire on est bien vivant pour finir
c'est toujours le même problème
bon tout proche 3 gagner des deux cdh
open moi je pense bêtement faire ça et
sûrement beaucoup mieux j'aime être ok
juste part affiché en fait empêché on a
envie de se la faire damer fuite je
pense le plus fort mais en fait n'est
fait car ce que voilà lui son point fort
ça est maintenant fait on est sur son
point fort le mec est nul mais il se
doit il se battrait très bien bon là tu
étais quand même bien en avance donc ça
va mais sinon ils se battraient très
bien sûr je pense que c'est too much et
la position n'est pas assez il ya passé
deux des pièges éventuels messinis va
bien la loi on le suppose un nom je
n'étais pas en danger ou quoi de n'y a
pas de piège spécifique ou quoi gère ça
va c'est pas une position ya pire
mais bon c'est pas fini puisque ton foot
15 1 a du mal à s'activer et le pion à 4
a du mal à être protégé en fait ouais
vas te poses joue trop vite
trois ans n'en faut gérer pas qu'il va
nous reprendre le pion d'une manoeuvre
hautement crétine médaille je t'ai dit
qu'il t'a vu que savait que tout d'un
coup il s'est mis à bien joué j'ai envie
de te dire moi de sauce l'ouzbek non
c'était très smooth et puis la plus tout
le monde savait pas si on a encore
beaucoup mieux non non non plus mieux
peut-être encore un petit plus on est
tous réfutent mais il voit là là là il
se met à bien jouer tout d'un coup
c'est après que je fasse un photomontage
quand je quand je suis dans ma cuisine
que je suis un smoothie k&b cinquième
point 4 j'ai vu ça ici mais j'étais
étonné qu'il est ce une tactique passé
comme ça mais bon déjà rompu ce son
point fort et là tu l'as tu l'as bien
manoeuvré bruit pour vous tous nuls en
fait foi son aide
je veux
je vais peut-être même lui faire un
réseau de maths c'est ce que je pense
être tentés de faire
objectivement c'est gagnant ça ou pas on
se lèche ans
[ __ ] je parle bon là c'est plus
gagnant en fait j'ai un petit délai
sûreté que c'est assez désagréable quand
on quand on arrive dans le money time
mais ça arrive de temps en temps en fait
je sais pas d'où ça vient
peut-être ap le fou mais je sais pas et
ça m'a changé quatre fois tu arrive
juste au retard en fait
terrible cette fois mais c'est ça mon
gros défaut ceux ci en tant que je peux
garder quand on est comme ça laisse une
pièce sans r kelly mari font partie le
sud quand je fais des prix nous fait des
conneries c'est la grosse différence
je vais dormir parce qu'il va me prouver
urbina non mais je comprends en fait
c'est un peu idiot comme des fêtes
bastien fait jouer une pièce parce que
je sais pas ce que tu as chaud là je
vois pas de l'attaqué mais juste parce
que je pense que je gère pas les coûts
très bas explique tu joues et tu vois
phase et que tu vois la souris de
l'adversaire bouger sur l'étudiant fait
un peu comme ça marche ouais exactement
métier que ce qu'elle pourrait aussi
savoir les projets dans les trucs à
faire qui pourrait être sympa rajouter
mais là ce serait merveilleux je vois tu
vois un peu vers où il valait le coup ça
sourit en fait ça pour les socios chanaz
se voit être carrément bien en fait
en revanche le chat sur twitch j'ai
jamais vu aussi endormie pas les mecs
mais ça devrait qu'il était un ses
juillet tout le monde est en vacances
non enfin twitter il ya du monde à une
centaine de personnes les mecs de choses
comme ça on serait content de voir ça en
fait fait gens sont très contents de
devoir jouer mais le chat des gens qui
sont là d'habitude fils sont très très
bon en fait non sous le régime ben ali
sont peut-être content que tu perdes par
rapport à pour record ouais c'est ça en
fait norman bien ce qui je ne suis pas
mort je dors indoor il est très fatigué
en fait c'est normal
as tu as envie de faire du sacrifice
garrec la fable envie de faire le beau
je suis pas comme un truc de débutants
beaucoup même pas pris une gramme data
tous des bons qui donnent je sais pas je
sais pas ma collection nike part
normalement pour non en fait c'est
simple on commence à savoir que ça lag
quand on a des soucis quand on se parle
en fait on la fait bien et très bien son
cavalier en d6 ce qui va faire le beau
jeu n'ont pas de chauffage
on s'en fout on est là pour s'amuser
j'arrivais genre est pas jouer juste
derrière cette démarche si c'est
confirmé a demandé de se défendre
genk est normal parce qu'ils ont un
escompte de devenir grand maître si on
commence à jouer sérieusement à 30 ans
normalement je pense pas mais bon après
les trucs sont faits pour être battus et
enfin les records sont faits pour être
battus non mais est rémy c'est possible
ça a déjà été fait en commençant par je
pense qu'un youtuber chess explained est
devenu ami il n'a pas commencé jeunes
gens après tout à fait dans le ton que
tu as à louer aussi un petit a
énormément de temps c'est possible
ce type de préparation n'aurait pas
sacrifier si tu vois ensemble dans une
position compliquée c'est juste archi
gagnant coup c'est de la merde au chat
ou pas on s'est tiré vers le bas mais
ces jeux du stream 1 allez-vous tour h
3à fava les boues je peux même comment
je chie comment je commence je suis pas
à tout racisme ou voilà combien tu fais
perpète ainsi jamais tel port de merak à
part les 26 mars prochain jordan gilles
domaine de l'utopie c'est fini ça sa
défense était tour à schwyz d'avoir ça
peut prendre perpète à la paix comme
jamais je me trompe mais non et tout
projet c'est bon
je normal finir les mecs la suite sur la
sûreté du beau jeu oui mes rêves ça
sympa suspect d'un match indécis dans la
justice qui existe entre les cases je
fais pousser 5 3 et 6 jets machin mais
bon tu fais ni federer n'est pas du
nadal tu vas tu monte à la volée tu
bosses tu as volé on peut aérien c'est
dommage m je suis très très déçu je
tenais la victoire avec le boulevard des
dames enfin qu'écraser alors c'est quoi
l'ordre des titres au juste avant le
premier grand maître a pressé m après
c'est maître fide et a pressé m
nationale est en fait entre gm et jérémy
a pas vraiment de différence a plus faim
je crois même que tous les grands
maintenant sont interdépendants et
internationaux la sexy des grottes
printemps sont enfin à l'époque où il
peut être battu ce même parti
c'est général
machine gun fille
je comprends jamais les gens connaissent
de xi plage en machine gun quoi 2003
c'est un peu ça le présomptueux non
comme comme nickname no way
bush à qui dit aller fabien reprend du
poil de la bête dans le jardin en fait
partie en fait les dégâts que ça
s'arrête
ouais je doublais suis tu prends ta
qualité en saint flour ça ce débouché tu
veux faire du magasin en fait est un
concept aussi je fais pas mal bon le mec
n'a pas pour objectif de prendre ta
qualité
non maj rebonds bon ben on le prend pas
la qualité
mm mettre un truc en d4 a choisi d'aller
faire qu'il y ait quatre personnes
nécessitent bien joué
malgré que décrypte 14 pourrait
s'appeler machine gun exactement vers
les sapeurs une machine gun gary
n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs vous à vous
abonner à la chaîne chaîne twitch que
vous regarde en ce moment par les
notifications ont fait des stream c'est
tous les jeudis soir 20h fab
ouais ouais donc c'est pas toujours ça
laisse très bon par contre on ne sait
pas quoi faire je vais jouer
ben ça dépend en fait un jeudi devait en
fait le seul stream qui est un petit peu
bon toujours pareil c'est le sait le cec
le 1er du mois en fait premier foyer
enfin on peut un tournant c'est le plus
marrant d'ailleurs je trouve enfin ses
monstres ils prennent des mails truc
c'est qu'on peut pas le faire trop
souvent parce que sinon après ça perd un
peu de son charme aussi et là aussi vous
pouvez retrouver les replays du stream
des stream sur sur la chaîne youtube sur
ce point comme ça se passe et jenson
courant de faire quoi conclut une chaîne
spéciale youtube.com français je pose
sur nous on sache qui qui qui n'est pas
qui n'est pas notre chaîne ceux-là qui
n'en est ce qu'il y aura une redif on le
stream spécial 5000 abonnés alors ouais
je vais laisser en faillite râle il se
rend long listait mais je mettrais un
lien dans notre réponse de réponse aux
commentaires en fait tu ferais une vidéo
spéciale réponse au commentaire ou c
coupé on répond simplement vos
commentaires
et du coup à l'inter de cette vidéo
torrent description un lien vers la
vidéo avec le live en complet puisque du
coup je vais pas faire deux vidéos il
faisait avec le live et puis remettra ça
aurait fait doublon on va décider de
faire comme ça donne pas les doublons
j'aime pas les doubles en feutre dans le
chef bachelot qui me demande si près du
but
je ne veux pas voir deux fois les mêmes
parties n'en a pas
qu'est ce que c'est que cette merde
ce serait très content il s'écoule qui
dans ce no ja lemay qui est d'ailleurs
dans les séries qu'on n'a pas encore
lancé
il ya notre série elle fut témoin cette
merde en fait pas encore lancé cette
série non aboutissement
enfin on va le faire ça c'est prévu
d'être fait du coup peut-être la
libération garé en fait ça nous permet
de lancer ça d'ailleurs ce que vous avez
fait deux fois la même partout au cours
de votre vie alors c'est des parties
très courte avec des maths et tout ça
probablement mais si on parle de partis
qui ont dépassé le 20e coup j'imagine
que non j'ai pas fabien à moins de mises
à part les trucs théorique un nom mais
pas loin de pond way fabien rey qui va y
aller en force
fabien qui a passé le pion des boues
fabien qui se rapproche du 2005 de
nouveau
l'exemple de gens qui sont nés qui sont
arrivés grand maître sur le tard à la
soixantaine alors avait-il commencé les
échecs genou pas toute leur mise aussi
aussi parfois il ya eu des thèmes d'aidé
titre de grand maître données de manière
honorifique à des joueurs qui je ne
serais jamais devenu grand maître mais
qui met qui ont obtenu le titre qui leur
a été donné je rappelle avoir vu en
italie
une fois je joue un tournoi à je sais
plus où d'ailleurs dans la vallée
d'aoste moi il y avait un papy qui avait
peut-être 95 ans ou 80 18 ans était
joueur actif le plus âgé du monde et il
est des grandes manoeuvres en fait à
mais il a minci 2007 jo et vieux ou oui
parce qu'il était le joueur le joueur
actif le plus le plus âgé du monde
du coup ils ont donné le titre de grand
maître un ok mais je joue encore à 19,1
avoir 18 cents à 90 ans 95 ans seront
pas sic il était actif 1 il avait l'air
très sympa
essence 1996 il est content écrit
bonsoir master en plus 1987 c'est une
année qui est très très très
intéressante
soit on saute photo nd naissance ouais
du coup ça rend l'année beaucoup plus
intéressante que les autres vous estimer
à combien le nombre de partisans que
vous avez fait dans votre vie a enfin vu
en faire beaucoup plus que moi et moi je
pense j'en ai vu faire plus d'un millier
c'est sûr nous premier exactement je
vais du mal à dire fabien je pensais de
tourner aux alentours de 5 6 me est
possible je sais pas que georges ou 100
tonnes par an alors mouais s'emparant en
vain en être sûr d'être cas de 3000 noms
mais c'est pas vrai c'est dur dont je
veux beaucoup c'est assez lent celle
entre mac rimouski dit jouant
exclusivement sur trois points comme
j'ai le compte exact on vise exactement
le nombre de parties jouées dans sa vie
c'est génial c'est super beau à lait
donc pour un jeu combien et nous battre
le dire
quoi
j'étais concentré à fond la petite
chauffe
non ce n'est pas tant sa reine le truc
c'est quand je joue en parlant que je
fais n'importe quoi
ben dhia pas trop lointain et voilà la
réponse complète pour aussi de pas fait
partie depuis 101 ces chiens juste
ridicule donc juste pour y défier saint
thomas lang concentration la lcp ni de
trouver des pièces en main là on n'est
pas obligé de joie parce que je sais
même pas ce n'est pas que je vois pas ça
me rassure attention pas faire et f3
dangereux mais je sens que lui il a son
rôle à jouer pour défendre je donne
effectivement bon sens avec ce mal et
par là
en fait je remarque quand tu joues
contre des maître fide ou des maîtres
nationaux quoi ils sont beaucoup moins
fort que toi mais ils sont pas mal en
pratique en fait ils réussissent bien à
ce qu'est ce que je veux dire la
gigoteuse
est ce que l'absence de carles scène
était la condition de la présence de
casques paraphes à saint louis à votre
avis ça c'est intéressant ça comme
question d'ailleurs c'est possible mais
bon on va dire vraiment qui est le
champion des seigneurs annuel reçoit le
titre de génie mais moi le truc c'est
que les seniors sont souvent génie en
fait pendant que c'est weisser en ce
moment le champion du monde et du coup
il est grand maître il disait format
tron mais ok donc on lui attribue q2
j'ai mis aussi me go deux manettes on
parle souvent mais ça où la concurrence
est globalement normal à mon avis ne
serait jamais venu ici car la scène
était là c'est possible difficile à dire
mais c'est possible on va dire je suis
plutôt d'accord avec toi normal
mol norman bates 31
tu fais le beau jeu waouh je suis pas
sûr après roy abc ce que tu sois aussi
bien en fait non attendue
très mal en fait le buzz rarement
rarement récompensé une nouvelle fois
c'est hyper dur c'est horrible fab
sur cette affaire car elle chez 7 pour
les jouer le père pète
as tu vas tomber fab fabien rend à
tomber
mais voilà il faut reconnaître qu'il a
pas mal figo t en milieu de partir non
mais c'est juste que je traiterai de
précision tintin georges pas tellement
ma critique lui 18 1871 partie lente
depuis 2011
quoi mais lente consolante ouais mais
lente tu vois tu comptes eux quelle
cadence sur internet veuillez vous
peut-être landes sur internet ces 15
minutes ou 20 minutes ce qu'on appelle
rapide en montréal en fait
mais même un c'est impressionnant note
joue beaucoup
qu'est ce qui est dit à rue semble très
calme cave il ya beaucoup de bruits qui
viennent qui viennent de ma rue il ya
beaucoup de son jeu n'ont pas trop
compte en fait mais c'est plutôt chez
toi c'est la nourrice plutôt la rue de
fab
parce que chez moi il ya vraiment rien
les coques et toutes tailles des coques
de partout et à des motos aussi souvent
j'ai l'impression qu'ils passeraient toi
or une route quoi il a été de nouveau
très très bien en fait lawrence où le
jeu c'est parti comme ça les mecs le
prédit koon fini quand le chien juste
hyper chiant tout à fait des crabes
c'est le même nom mais la session si la
pratique ou pas juste le temps j'en ai
ce qu'est ce qu'est ce que ces virées
nef alors c'est ça veut dire mettre fi
des fêtes cfi des masters mais en
français on écrit à l'envers face à nous
on est là on écrire white house house
toi et toi mais là du coup tu veux
affaire à six et justifier l'abandon
voilà je 14 coup c'est bien ça ouais
quel joueur le plus susceptible de faire
tomber karl scène un jour à votre avis
aronian gris chukka nouvelles ou autres
lire great chioukh web au lieu de jouer
parce qu'on aime bien vlad qui s'occupe
de lui et elles viennent parce qu'on
aime bien les français voient la
croissance durable ou pas ça peut être
un mec dont on sait pas trop mais qu'est
ce qu'est ce que tu sais quelle est la
place de wailly là par exemple alive
writing non ce n'est pas seulement un
jeu utilisera comme il est oui oui si tu
veux il est 15e
il a 18 piges le gamin quand même
dangereux barbet soir ça peut être des
gens comme ça longtemps
avec ce calibur ce terrain qui trop
chaud
belle rencontre la fille dort ouais
c'est donc normal valls sur i will i
fans qui viennent championne du monde
mélissa sans le bac ça c'est impossible
à tripoli pas sauf s'ils font un format
coton crétins et qu'on jette des déchets
pas comme si non non donc si on joue
avec des dépôts est possible mais non
impossible trop trop gros écarts de
niveaux bon mon roi le plus faible du
coup mon truc très bonne je vous salue
qui auraient pu éventuellement devenir
championne du monde sur un malentendu
revanche je sais pas le gars ouais elle
avait le niveau pour lequel est né un
peu moins forte que gary et d'autres
joueurs mais elle aurait pu
non on peut lire belle et elle a battu
le record de précocité pas de grand
maître
donc c'est pas hasard et il ya donc
voilà qu'une telle vente à 14 ans voit
quelque chose derrière travaille
beaucoup les et soeurs le père les
entraîneurs de faire des stages
d'entraînement avec des grands maîtres
j'ai lu à peu son livre là nous raconte
sa vie et ça rigolait pas prêt c'est un
gros talent on peut le gars là on aurait
pu pas après tu vois pas trop de monde
ce jour c'est pas tout et qu'il est
parvenu à très peu dans l'histoire c'est
une candidate potentielle mais oui fans
très très loin de ça c'est surtout par
rapport à rully fans mais que je veux
faire le parallèle pour dire que woman
elle est très très loin du niveau
qu'avec avait pas le gard elles
participent au tournoi tout ça parce
qu'à les invitations comme pour le grand
prix c'est pas comme pôle gare qui était
vraiment qui méritait juste au vélo en
fait de jouer ce tournoi était juste
qualifié bon allez vous allez en fait ya
cette histoire incroyable c'est que les
arbitres c'est ma crise qui parle de ça
en fait j'ai pas si tu as lu mais mais
en fait à nantes a fait un coup illégal
oui en faisant arrêter demain et larbi
juste à côté
mec n'a pas déclaré victor akrami qu'en
fait c'est un truc qui m'a halluciné
toujours en étant à 17 c'est que j'ai
l'impression que les arbitres sont
absolument inutile en fait j'ai un
métier où ils ont passé plus difficile
d'arbitrage à une partie d'échecs un
match de foot en fait ils font plus
souvent théoriquement de fautes
d'arbitrage c'est un truc qui m'a lucide
en fait face à chaque fois non mais la
fois la rague ne l'aiment pas bien la
mediapad non mais c'est pas et c'est
comme si le tennis la balle est faute
irvine on est les deux à trois mètres
derrière la ligne mais je te raconte
juste je sais pas mais il ya de bonnes
basses et ça va mais toi c'est
hallucinant en fait c'est tellement
simple arbitre est en fait le mec
utilise demain tu j'arrive pas à
comprendre en fait fable pas toi ça te
ça tu vas pas non mais bon c'est passé
comme si au foot y'a un mec qui met un
coup de poing à un autre mais que
l'arbitré juste devant qu'il le voit et
qui dit non ça joue quoi enfin je sais
pas mais c'est enfin tard m 2 arbitres
pour cinq parties d'échecs enfin je ne
sais pas ça joue sajou au football tu as
trois arbitres et à plein de rue qui se
passe de partout où l'attend à 2 pour
cinq parties d'échecs et là il restait
plus qu'une partie sur l'autre qu'ils
étaient 2 pour une partie facile mais ça
me paraît quand même arbitre et non mes
joueurs ça arrive très souvent en fait
ça me paraît quand même assez dingue
toi ça te choque pas non mais n'aime pas
que les arbitres ne respectent pas la
règle je serai content les règles sont
faits pour être suivi ou pas n'ont été
repérées par les joueurs peut-être pas
d'ailleurs cramique n'a pas réclamé mais
l'arbitré le ghana vous faire respecter
la règle non des fois je comprends
j'entends totalement le sait ce que
c'est que ça bon je suis à bout la
résine si c'était la fille folle de la
fidh en parlerait déjà deux procès pour
corruption peut-être fou peut-être pas
jusque là mais on parle mais même au
foot contre des règles c'est litigieux
c'est à l'intention qui rentre en compte
machin là en fait il joue un coup à
demain mais fait face à face à l éthique
promotion donc il joue son pion avec la
main droite il va attraper la pièce la
bac l'autre à prix doux vient cavaliers
avec sa main gauche vas-y et séduire tu
veux pas te sens tu entends qui me dira
et puis pose aux cavaliers et l'a10 voit
sa couche à donner je comprends ta part
déjà demain affaire georges d'un drap de
plage ma gauche cela que tu gagne du
temps c'est intentionnel tu vas vite
donc tu gagne du temps et tu ton
adversaire
non mais moi j'ai rien d'assez juste que
la règle et autres bons débits les 1 me
contenterai darby de l'interprète à sa
non mais je pense pas qu'il ya un
terreau pression ça qu'ils pensent et
d'interprètes rien du tout faire mais je
pense juste que ils n'interviennent
jamais n'ont rien en fait pas plus que
vous verrez un trou si c'est ça c'est ça
s'est passé parce que si c'était une
question d'interprétation choix
d'accessoires en fait les mecs ne voit
jamais rien fait mais mais non mais
c'est un peu comme au foot c'est à la
main décollée du corps et que la balle
arrive au ballon et que tu arrêtes un
but en fait c'est pas un optionnel mais
il ya penalty quand même un chez ba oui
et épaulettes rouges lâchés en tout mais
bon j'ai re que l'aller les rares et s
était évidente à tout ça mais j'habite
relevé
metric ça que j'ai jamais trop compris
le truc mais il a rarement vu des
faussetés grand meeting à non ils ont
fait exactement lamerat aux championnats
du canada en fait il ya exactement la
même erreur d'arbitrage
c'est exactement la même du coup face
c'est juste je me demande pourquoi on
allait des arbitres pourraient arbitrer
entre nous en fait oui généralement dans
sa des trucs dans l'esprit et les voilà
quoi non mais en fait je comprends
pourquoi ils ont fait cette règle c'est
jusque il voudrait que le sport devienne
un peu plus médiatique en fait et pour
avoir un sport médiatique faut avoir des
règles claires et en blitz en fait c'est
très souvent n'importe quoi en fait sur
la mêlée reds et ceci se passe sur
l'échiquier va demain avec vos questions
si tu renverses des pièces non metronomy
combien de fois j'ai vu des gens par
exemple qui touche la pièce avant que tu
es fini d'effectuer ton coup ça arrive
hyper souvent dons qui sont obligés de
mettre des règles pour cadrer le truc
femmes c'est normal fasse jour tu vas
avoir un sport médiatisé tu dois voir
des règles c'est normal c'est enfin moi
ça me paraît tout à fait logique en fait
c'est pour ça qu'ils font ces règles-là
est en fait moi plutôt un bien non mais
en fait en gros mais bon après ça c'est
un point de vue moi j'aime bien qui
truste serait strictement l'esprit il en
va des ce qui se passait en droite ou
des fois tu as des mecs innocenté parce
que parce qu'il ya vice de forme
ou parce que machin mais non pas dans
l'est dans l'esprit tu as triché si dans
l'esprit tu as volé bas c'est beaucoup
plus grave que parce que c'est un grand
sens de son fondateur fois ce que tu dis
c'est pas faux mais le truc c'est que
vous diront les arbitres sont là pour
faire respecter la règle et que du coup
ils sont là pour pour s'assurer que le
sport puisse devenir médiatique et tout
ça et il faut que les joueurs
s'habituent si tu veux c'est juste que
une fois que tu auras sanctionné de
trois fois des mecs là plus personne qui
le fera et en fait ce sera très très
bien faut juste que la règle elle soit
employé de trois fois pour donner un
exemple sinon c'est l'anarchie
combien de fois je venais à camurac on
tbilissi mais jamais les pièces est au
centre des cases et tout ça il fait
n'importe quoi father disqualifie de
deux fois et tu verras pas là il aurait
fait beaucoup moins d'ailleurs mais dans
un moment il le faisait un peu je vais
te rappelles tu as élite sais c'est un
peu n'importe quoi hiroki avec demain
files et un truc comme ça en fait non
marocaine a annoncé
responded jardin ok les pièces sont à
l'autre bout de la salle et à deux on a
répondu du coup on n'a plus affaire
promotion quand on est mal autant c'est
quoi la c'est quoi l'idée ce que le
projet le problème depuis promotion de
deux ans a pendu des plus gros sont là
je débarque toi mais des fois faudra
aussi que là que se fait par des
parisiens qui prennent au foot parce que
des fois et la fifa fait des règles qui
pourraient sembler basique mais donc
aussi les genres de chuck qui faisait la
dèche a peut-être mais le problème au
rugby mais le rugby regarde ce qui s'est
passé eu des problèmes avec
l'interprétation des de l'arbitrage
vidéo les arbitres ils ont suivi l'arrêt
qui avaient été données ce qui est tout
à fait normal ils sont là pour le faire
ensuite j'ai eu des problèmes ça a causé
des problèmes un peu comme on l'a on a
eu aux échecs et au final et aucun excès
passés ils ont changé la règle après
coup mais géré par le gouvernement si
personne ne fait jamais respecter
n'importe quelle règle la fin tu as peur
tu ne peux pas avancer
enfin faut faire défaire des pas faire
des pas en travaux faut faire des pas en
avant tu ne peux pas toujours rien
arbitres et ce comme aux échecs son
adversaire fait un pièce touché pièce à
jouer face à absolument n'importe quoi
pas les mecs ne vont pas moi ça m'est
déjà arrivé en fait
enfin il m'est déjà arrivé deux trois
fois que mes adversaires tricheurs passe
deux mois sur des trucs comme ça
elarbi tu n'as jamais fait respecter la
règle en fait c'est peut-être ça qui
fait merveille en fait jamais non je
n'ai pas vu je m'en fiche
ah non pas la prochaine fois que tu fais
tu ne peux plus le faire mais non il
vient de le faire une fois en fait ah
non mais comme j'ai pas vu il n'ya pas
il ya pas de basse est tombé titre
regarder quand même enfin dans le
snj-cgt et fo juste ses imprimeries pour
parler du rôle de l'arbitré aux échappés
sont passés juste un problème récurrent
en fait après ça raconte en doutiez ces
trois manches 1 ouais je sais qu'on
tende à part les projets seront choisis
après ça reste mon opinion sur ce qu'on
a enlevé l'or par exemple c'est un
christ qui nous parle de ça et il dit
juste on qui est exactement le même
problème ce que disait aux surfeurs du
canada exactement le même truc lhermitte
n'a rien fait mais en fait c'est plus ça
c'est pas vraiment sur le cas de la
partie d'alain c'est juste c'est
récurrent en fait ce problème là je la
sais un petit peu médiatique parce que
la règle est échangé le 1er juillet et
que c'est anachronique mais en fait dans
tous les toits du monde ça arrive tout
le temps
en fait on parle d bah oui justement sur
l'arbitrage de déchets par du temps en
fait je ne sais pas à quoi ça sert à
quelque chose quand même surtout encore
les salles de jeu où il ya 100 joueurs
pour quatre arbitres je blâme pas du
tout les arbitres parce que c'est
quasiment impossible de tout voir mais
là quand même ils sont deux pour une
partie ne faut pas abuser puisse
contraindre habiterait un truc hyper dur
quand ils ont un truc à regarder c'est
que les mecs vous avec une en mai fable
quand même faut abuser
enfin il faut arrêter quoi ça sinon on
n'est pas l'arbitré puis on fait du
switch est ce qu on fait comme des
pistes dans y'a pas de problème on vit
entre new normal mais mon coeur je
découvris ego doigt puis je décide que
les pièces de jeu différemment pour
cette partie tu vas norman baisse qui
dit les arbitres devront d'être
respectés avoir une place il faut qu'il
montre qu'il est là il se fasse
respecter s'il n'est pas là quand on a
besoin de lui trois points de suspension
c'est un peu c'est un peu ça va le truc
d'après c'est bon pour mon point de vue
donc à mobiliser j'ai pas grand chose à
voir ya des gens qui ont écrit sur
twitter ce n'est qu'il est avéré qu elle
invite à son libre arbitre et bon bah
ouais je pense que c'est un peu toujours
soumis à l'interprétation des trucs mais
non mais surtout là le truc d'aaland
aussi que les gens revoient leurs ailes
nancy trucs plus cohérent mais là c'est
quand tu fais une promotion que droits
de l'attrapé la pièce avec notre main
puis c'est violent alain mais il faut
que les règles soient changés là dessus
on est d'accord mais il faut quand même
fin vers le rôle c'est quand même de la
faire respecter sinon à quoi ça sert
d'avoir des règles enfin pourquoi est ce
que je dis bac demain que j'ai envie que
madame bouge comme un cavalier quoi
je trouve la règle complètement débile a
la bougeotte rodez mais bon c'est dans
les règles dans la rue turgot je compte
faire ton choix si ce que tu admires
dans ma cave et faire flouer à 3 en fait
mort il ya d'abord un 1 devant je suis
en face salon il peut faire ils peuvent
faire le 5-fu si ça peut vous laisser
dans l'ombre mois oui mais c'est dans
l'esprit tu as une division l'arrivée de
la vidéo aux échecs
c'est génial qu'est ce qui ce qui n'est
pas content de nadal nadal prend
régulièrement plus de 20 secondes entre
deux services mais je suis d'accord avec
toi
entre deux points pourtant il reçoit pas
dormi mais je sais et moi aussi ça
m'énerve à chaque fois et même contre
gilles muller il a fait plein de fois là
à chaque fois il prend énormément de
temps et j'étais très énervé et il
menace les arbitres aussi je ne je suis
d'accord avec qui ce qu'il en fait je
vais pouvoir aller n'est rien au tennis
quoi on a rit oui et tu ne m'as vu tu
seras plus là mais en fait d'ailleurs et
moi non plus j'ai pas trop compris que
ça allait on ces tensions étaient
parlées en plus j'ai dit je comprends
pas comment tu te rends pas une
suspension après avoir dit de telles
choses en fait ok ça je comprends pas
mais si pas du tout l'histoire des cta
plus médiatique du sénat un pouilly fans
qui fait rêve 3g cadre des trois
variantes de gibraltar tu fais ça
n'apporte qu'une vérité soit est
suspendu août est finalement rayé un
truc quoi le nom bien joli grand prix
c'est très très bien ce que tu fais bah
non je suis pas sur mais bon ok mauvais
exemple pour les enfants
donc en fait dès que des critères de
notoriété et machin
on ne touche moins tu as traitement de
faveur quelque part entre cannes nadal
une bombe à la dans le cas où il fallait
très différents mais a limité ses
suivants tu soit puissant ou misérable
tout ça déjà victor hugo savalli mais ça
ne touche pas que le sport effectivement
sport mais dans le sport justement ça
devrait être un endroit où on est un peu
comment dire protéger et voir les choses
d'une lueur et et tout ça non mais la
championne du canada puis ce qui est
très très drôle c'est que le joueur
avait fait avait fait une tour à
l'envers pour faire une dame parce
qu'ils trouvaient pas la dame et blitz
et mais il a fêté avec demain et du coup
l'arbitré a dit non c'est une tour c'est
pas une dame donc arbitres a fait
respecter la règle de la tour mais n'a
pas fait respecter la règle de
situationnisme il fait respecter les
règles et période on a un peu
l'impression qu'il ne connaît pas les
règles en fait ça donne quand même cette
impression puisque la règle de la tour à
l'envers qui ne peut pas être une dame
dans l'esprit c'est pas très juste non
pas non mais tu me suces trouve pas la
dame pour une tourte et une seconde sur
la pendule ça tu fais ce que tu peux
après c'est à toi aussi à retrouver
l'amour avant mais géré par la fin si tu
fais respecter la règle fait respecter
la dre règle pas tu fais pas respecter
les règles que tu as envie tu vois ce
que je veux dire t'as pas ton libre
arbitre quand même quand un arbitre ou
venant non d'agir tarn tu écris pas les
règles d'inspection écrit des choses oui
tu vas dire aujourd'hui non c'est la
rive la tour à l'embarquement en vue de
faire respecter l'autre règle ça ne
m'intéresse pas tu devrais avoir une
commission de discipline c'est après
comme dans tout laisse croire qu'ils
sont discipline pour les arbitres et
ipad a fait une très grosse erreur
d'arbitrage du couté relégué le tüv
arbitre de ligue 2 ça en fait ouais
n'est ce pas un guide de canadian
ensuite se passe dans tous les sports en
fait peut-être que les arbitres avaient
raison dans le fond quoi je sais pas
c'était un rebelle et tout mais du coup
tu es plus en champion's league
après je ne sais pas c'est un débat
quelles qu'en penses-tu l'équipe et les
échiquiers dgt de détecteurs d'actions
illégales ma difficile en fait parce que
tu es dégâts serait juste de toucher une
classe et de perles a joué tout ça mais
commandes des gt pourrait voir que tu as
tu fait une pièce jeux d'échecs
enclencherait une alarme sonore au moins
pour attirer l'attention de l'arbitré
endormi
maintenant je crois qu'il faut qu'on
passe à la vidéo aux échecs c'est je
pensais comme cana bus avec les échecs
c'est très difficile à filmer
donc si vous attendez beaucoup de moyens
d'avoir du public un échiquier connectés
mais je pensais beaucoup trop dur à
arbitrer c'est chaque fois c'est un
sport soit beaucoup trop compliqué faut
aux périodes échecs nos coeurs alors
fans du groupe dans ce moule non
donc si on a tous compris que tu allais
falise army kevin tu as les règles en
fait et j'aime bien à jamais en fait
comment les matchs de rugby sont
arbitrés en général où tu as quand même
l'esprit de l'arbitré machin et ça
j'aime bien en fait
l'auraient-ils forains arbitres sur
l'échiquier deux arbitres de touche par
partie par partie
j'étais encore et deux arbitres qui
s'est hissé sur la deuxième est la
septième rangée il tuerait été que c'est
puissant radar vide plus générale serait
trois bons abondance option l'allemagne
ne veut pas prendre tout ça marche je te
préviens j'espère j'espère gagner grâce
à cette règle non meuse on va dans une
zone de gagner quand je joue à la loyale
que si je suis plus fort je gagne je
suis une femme je perds un pionnier
parce que même une promotion avec deux
dindes main même et cyrine prises avec
de minces et fait aussi oui notre adepte
mais je comprends pas encore ce mail à
lavera en compte nos demandes mais là le
jour je vous invite d'ailleurs dimanche
enfin bref encore une partie je vous
promets que le mec me renverse un petit
une pièce et sans faire exprès bon je
pense je peux garde quand même bien
maintenant un peignoir bon j'ai pas très
joli nom mais qui est à droite c'est pas
intentionnel tu as le droit mais je suis
intentionnels qui est alors versée qu'en
mairie la remise avant d'appuyer sur la
pendule ou pas non non il a joué le pct
parti il a fait sur la peau nue pendant
que la pièce était par terre wen ont
tous accepté arrive pas c'était jeudi la
mairie spray coiffant dire ça mais on
fait quoi la france mais pointilleux
machin ou si je devais beaucoup c'est
pas demain dit mme rice et des pièces à
la tronche à chaque coup quoi la mettons
enfin je n'étais pas t'es pas obligé de
le demande
mais je fais ce que tu veux en fait en
tant que voix
norman qui l'année dernière c'est très
sympa il part d'une grande chaise
souriez plein de gosses etc
ce n'est pas en mettant les joueurs en
vase clos sans ambiance qu'on va
populariser les échecs vous hörmann
betts complètement kelly g avec ce
commentaire
en fait j'ai remarqué on s'est fait la
réflexion avec fable si vous regardez un
match de foot par exemple qui à huis
clos
ça ne beaucoup moins envie de le
regarder à la télé quand le stade est
plein en fait et c'est pareil pour le
tennis en fête
le fait d'avoir le public ça donne envie
de regarder c'est comme un message
inconscient je pense tu sais ça doit
être étudiant en sociologie
je pense quand tu vois qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui aiment un truc tu as envie
de l'aimer aussi éventuellement couteau
toi je suis sûr qu'il ya un truc qui a
lié ces comités ont dit le monde attire
le monde émergent un train d'argent -
option tout ça mais on connaît le monde
attire le monde mais aussi puisque
peut-être mon père et restaurateurs du
mexique dans un récent quand il n'y a
personne en fait la personne qui a envie
de venir
ouais je savais rien des 2 be what is
not enough
mais en fait ce plan c'est pareil pour
le sport bien personne ne regarde donc
du coup nos postes intéressants
c'est ça en fait ouais il vous je suis
complètement sûr que le public c'est un
c'est important dans tout ce qu'on
regarde en fait ne nous on est fait
comme ça c'est sûr que ça existe est ce
que vous savez ouais en fait ils ont ils
ont fait ça parce que je disais que
c'était trop difficile de suite de
filmer les échecs avec du public c'est
beaucoup plus cher de faire en extérieur
du coup ils ont fait dans les studio
canal directement c'est parvenir garros
qui disent ceci je faire payer sans
changer pas trop je suis pas exactement
qui a imposé à quoi d'organiser ça
l'inter donc je vais pas me prononcer
sur un truc dont je suis pas exactement
au courant mais d'après ce que j'ai
compris c'était c'était pour faire des
économies au niveau 2 au niveau de la
production de l'émission télé et moi
mais oui très étonnant en fait le fruit
du public
mais cette menace coupes sexy
non mais c'est ni sa fable du tout
content très énervé
dallier poungui pour aller dans le sens
de kevin jarre et et les échecs six mois
à cause d'une erreur d'arbitrage
volontaire j'ai un élève aussi qu'il ya
un problème d'arbitrage d'erreurs
d'arbitrage volontaires qu'elle souhaite
ça mais c'était par équiper l'arbitré
claude sport jaro au foot
les arbitres de touche souvent c'est des
mecs du club qui font la buvette et
contient vient d un drapeau qui est par
le principal bon lui normalement c'est
vrai mais j'arrive à ma propre ou
d'arbitrer un match en tant qu'arme de
touche bons mots jetés pour aucune des
deux équipes
finalement il y avait qu un qualifié qui
arrivait mais mes côtés situe à 6 mois
je le retrouve à arbitrer un match mais
sur un match de synthés au foot et reiss
est très compliqué non à base et pas
forcément très objectif
non mais c'est pas évident difficile à
dire d'être partial non mais c'est hyper
dur en fait mais je suis surtout que les
règles en fait sont pas tout le temps
dans l'esprit
mais là c'est plus beaucoup de temps ce
cadre une cuisse est content le jeune
enseignant fait ils sont contents delà
de la retransmission qu'ils ont fait
mais je crois pas que ça ait fait en
tout cas sur internet ça m'a fait de
grosses audiences du coup non d'où il se
bat avec nos audiences avec flatte mais
nous aussi on est en intérieur en fait
non le studio gridstream viriat et du
coup puisque j'entraîne tous les niveaux
ouais mais jusqu'à 2200 pas plus au
dessus on traite le mien famille russie
qui entraîne tous les niveaux jusqu'à
2004 et entraîne d'ailleurs pour
l'instant j'ai perdu 2,4 autour de nous
trois cents au maximum as-tu contre le
joueur le plus chiant du site a même un
contre moi ils jouaient varions des
changes de la slave sur toutes les
pièces un maximum mais là du coup j'ai
pas ce qu'il fait mais en fait après
celle entraînée sait jamais quand je pas
avec l'équipe de france il a l'air gelé
s'entraîne vraiment une étrange affaire
seconde ans un truc que je peux faire
tuer en décharge
donc en fait le côté seconde en ça c'est
autre chose
déjà c'est pas c'est parce qu'entraîneur
après entraîné oui c'est quand même très
différent que 2 secondes et en fait toi
tu peux préparer des gens pour des
parties et c'est autre chose que les
entraîner à l'année
je suis un peu le travail de vlad
voilà ce que vlad c'est l'entraîneur on
est chauds ou pas on sait par contre
c'est tout pourri toute sa vie si tu
avais un vlad là tu serais tout pour toi
non non mais bloqués à l'entrée
évidemment mais il faut signaler sa
machine explique la vie il a été
entraîneur coach mental il fait tout
mais bon tu fais la cuisine
il sait qu'il fait très bien la soupe au
poulet ouais je sais y en a pas très
contente a soufflé il serait très
heureux du coup il fait la cuisine les
chefs dit éthiciens passé il fait tout
qu'est ce que je touche mon truc grand
roque
en fait c'est fantastique il veut même
expliqué comment t'occuper de tes gars
baby sitter c'est génial chasser les ai
tous connaissaient rien nous venons à
tous
mais c'est marrant parce que contre moi
ils jouent pas du tout comme ça en fait
le biostatisticien fondement il échange
tout bon on te respecte pa on voudrait
il veut mater au vatican un malade et je
fais partie compliquée je pense qu'il ne
t'aime pas je suis pas sûr que tu aimes
bien nous aussi
jd calme qui écrite est jean test
tu as l'air pas mal j'suis pas votre
jeune pas tellement on va bluffer en
temps fou mais je pense que c'est
complètement pourri que position car
genre fois je sais ce que je pars pour
ça est-ce que je prends d'abord en d4
où peut on s'en fout faire ça
je doive davids impression bon je serais
fou et je vous le rappelle la fosse où
j'ai eu dix bars justement ça toi mais
[Musique]
je vois ça j'ai doublé les tours car
c'est la dernière partie fin des
discussions finales
allez bon jeu notoire des huit tours dh
un tour d2 fujitsu plonge de 8 ans et
non le mec ne fais pas ça pour y chanter
pour moi sera en fait le coup j'ai six
en réalité tu es en fait il fait juste
faire une découverte ce que tu voulais
faire en fait tu vois il n'a pas appris
en d1 au moins avant pourtant maintenant
à ce que ce cas il prend un coup j'ai eu
dans cette note aussi des trois fuites
qui je pense a semblé travail normal
fatigue a mal joué un truc mais qui vont
maintenant pouvoir quand même fini mais
je crois qu'on peut au moins faire
rentrer comme ça le karaté non mais je
veux pas me permettre
j'ai pas envie mais pas mal de trucs qui
gagne à mon avis mais bon il faut
trouver le bon
oui le matos en fait
[Musique]
vraiment ce que je calcule n'importe
quoi chiba totalement ou s'ils ont un
truc là je vais pas te dire ta merde
il ya un autre stream qui devra dans une
nuit dernière
j'en sais rien je lui avais mon force
c'est ce que je voyais en fait avec
tourcoing f8 faire vite non je voulais
le faire et je vais tout reprendre et
fluide et surtout pour ainsi sur pie vii
et ça allait je veux faire ça non
sécurisé que laroque ici mais je crois
que ça m'a jamais leurs deux tours j'ai
un regret c'est de ne relever trois
baies 3 il ya plus d'échecs adam
français quatre ans un hangar voisin
français
4 parce que dans me2 pas possible et
surtour c'est un roi b3 troupes en c3
j'en prends un bon jeu ok j'ai repris la
mire du sympathique
après peut-être peut-être pas mal
objectivement oui tu vas tu approché de
2005 qui sera portée de fusil
quels sont exactement là tu attends
attends d'un bon j'ai vu celui-là je
sais pas je suis allé voir ma bio bio
machin je dois y aller
voilà on a pris 50 points elo décliner
et on se retrouve ben on retrouve jeudi
prochain toi tu reviendras dans trois
semaines
et ouais ouais ouais de la semaine
prochaine sur les des bulles est chaud
ok donc queiroz se dire la cure la
souffrance est fini des hawks imoca
simon voilà reste un vrai os
à bientôt a dit ça me go sérieuses
amigos